what's up everyone I'm chef Jay Jay
Johnson and I'm here today making my
famous smoked pork belly on the woodwind
SG by Camp Chef look at this pork belly
it looks truly amazing so the first
thing I'll do is I will dice this into
one and a half inch cubes this will help
speed up the smoking process I'm just
using a simple spice rub here because
the pork belly is gonna absorb the
amazing flavor from the smoker the first
time that I had made pork belly I
overcooked it I burnt it it had no
flavor so you don't have to make the
mistakes I did
the wood 1sg does it all so if you never
have pork belly this is gonna change
your life I'm making my barbecue sauce
right here on the side kick so I can
check on my pork belly and I don't have
to go in the kitchen at all typically I
use a psychic to sear meats burgers or
steaks it's a chef's fantasy I know you
go into restaurants and you see these
wood stoves and you see chefs cooking on
them I cook I cook on a wood stove I
love the open flame but the greatest
thing about this grill is you can remove
the bottom grate and you have that open
flame and you just control it with the
knob so today I'm smoking pork belly but
tomorrow I might be grilling burgers
steaks or even Bronx but it's still in
the traditional wood fire flame so this
pork belly is done and I'm gonna throw
it back into the smoker to get some
amazing carmelization
a camp chef is the perfect tool for
hosting there's nothing like bringing
friends and family over and feeding them
the most amazing food so hosting is it's
just in my blood to my DNA
[Music]